i'm actually grateful that the shake
might be
cancelled because i have not lo i love a
hug but i haven't loved a shake
in a while for that reason because
people are like hey
so nice to meet you and i'm like whoa
what no
and that was like way pre-covered but
the shake
i'm i mean i'm not a professor so i
could be citing this wrong but i think
it comes from
like back in the days when you know we
would meet up in the middle of the field
from separate
tribes and we would shake each other's
hand to show that we don't have a weapon
right you'd offer your hand and i just
feel like that's
kind of not necessary anymore why are we
shaking
let's just be like what's up well now
the hand is the weapon
very good point so the best thing to do
is be like
hi how are you yes i agree i
i've gotten a lot of uh clams in my
hands too
like i've gotten quite a few clammy
handshakes
throughout you know and it's true and i
you don't want to be seen doing the wipe
and being rude and you know asking for
purell but
we've we're free of that now we're free
of it now you know what used to be my
thing is that
if you shake someone's hand like if they
go for you really excited for a
handshake but you keep your hand
you extend it utterly limp like don't
tense any of the muscles and just let
them
shake it it feels crazy and i used to
give a lot of limp handshakes just to
keep myself
entertained i noticed you drinking a
giant
jug of something what's in it may i ask
green tea
coffee makes me have a slump and i
cannot afford a slump
right because i'm allergic to
inefficiency so having coffee even
though
sometimes it's delicious it's not
efficient so i gotta do that green tea
in the main vein you know also i'm a
little convinced
that tea has like preserved me because
i haven't lived the most perfect healthy
life and
it's probably genetics or whatever but
i'm like i've drank iced tea all day
long
my entire life and i'm convinced it's
preserved me
you know how many different kinds of tea
leaves there are in the world
no one
it all comes from the same leaf it's how
it's dried
all the different teas really can you
believe that
yes black green rubios
i mean there's thousands of different
types of tea and it's all from one leaf
fun fact
i know right um by the way have you done
the new
fun thing on the internet everybody's
doing and it's not even the internet i
don't know what i'm talking about
social i guess where you put yourself on
someone that rhymes with you or
i haven't i've thought about it but i'm
trying to figure out which
i was gonna do hell on bell and do a
bunch of flames and then i'm like no i
feel like that kid
i don't know some people might not like
that but then i don't know maybe maybe
cover myself in cheese swiss on chris
who knows
i like anything to do with cheese i like
and um i put myself drew uh
on a on a loo lucy lou
i know many of us have spent our
existence is we're
stressing out stressing about the thing
we're not doing
like just when you're at work you're
worried about kids when your kids
you know you're worried am i checking
the boxes and it's just
it's so relatable what was the
revelation in the execution
it was just a lot of um sort of uh
introspection about what are the
patterns that don't make me happy and
the patterns are that i always feel like
i want to be somewhere else like did you
see jerry seinfeld's new special it's so
funny and he talks about how everybody
like
nobody wants to be anywhere because
everyone's like are we going to go are
we going to go and then we get to the
movies
what time are we gonna get home and he's
like nobody wants to be anywhere and
i wanna be where i am so i just sort of
made that mental commitment and i don't
nail it all the time but at least i'm
trying setting the intention is is
pretty powerful because then
you can just adjust those patterns
without you know feeling like you
haven't
have to do an overhaul on your life it's
just clear in everything you do whether
it's a lord jones the cbd line the hello
bellow
the lazy boy like everything you do
really has this authentic you
in it and that's you
doing that i can't i don't i can do it
otherwise to be honest like
i'm not that good of an actor do you
know what i mean like
yes i say that sometimes too and people
go don't disrespect what i like about
you and i'm like
but that isn't who i am yeah yeah i can
only do what i know which is when i'm
ever exploring working with a company
a it goes through a lot of like most
emotional vetting of like does this
company have the give backs that i like
are they like are they doing things
right are they treating their employees
well are they good to their customers
and if all that checks out then i go
okay
i'd love to work with you but you're
gonna get the full picture which is i'm
gonna bring up some ideas that might
scare your marketing team which is like
what if we did this with no makeup what
if we did this with a messy room what if
you know i just think those ideas are
really important and they're
they're not shown enough and the real
situation that human beings go through
because it's like
hard to live on planet earth it's pretty
rough for
a lot of people even you know and
everybody's got
different privileges but generally being
a human being is
is trying and i just want to sort of
acknowledge the struggle we're all
having and bring some peace and some
happiness
amidst the chaos and it's so wonderfully
fulfilling if you get to do something at
the end of the day because
i always feel like then it gets to be
shared with people and that's the whole
point of why
you make a tv show or a movie it's not
indulgent it's like you want something
to go out in the world you make it it's
not no longer yours
you're just trying to share something
that means something to you
with other people and i know the
branding you do is no different
that's well i tried to be like if i was
sitting in your medicine cabinet what
would i look like
like this that's what i would like i
love the coloration by the way it's so
it is happy
happy dance is such a fantastic name i
have to do things that i feel
like responsible for and when i'm sort
of like emotionally moved by something
or it's really helped me i'm like let me
leverage
myself and be like yeah well i'll create
this with you i'll talk about it but
you'll put the price point will be
something people can afford
it will be on a shelf where people can
find it and i don't really do
anything these days without a give back
and we we formed happy dance we're
giving one percent of our profits to
this unreal organization
started by susan burton who lives in los
angeles
called a new way of life and uh
they she basically started it by she was
in and out of prison she got sober she
got her life together
then she decided to help other people
but she said i don't have anything but
these two hands
oh i guess i'll use them doy so she
started
meeting women at the drop-off point when
they'd get uh released from
incarceration
and she would bring them home and she'd
say how can i help you do we need to get
your kids back let's find a lawyer do we
need to get you housing you can live
here for a while and she now has 10
homes
that are housing i mean they've helped
like 2 000 women and it's all about
formerly incarcerated women who are
trying to get their lives back on track
who
want to be sober who want to get their
kids back and she i just want her to
have access to
all the funding in the world because i
think she does amazing work and so happy
dance is
very proud to give one percent of our
our profits to them
[Music]
you